iPhone se الجديد
منذ البداية صممنا
iphone sc ليشمل بعض
الميزات والتقنيات الأكثر تقدمًا مع
تقديم تجربة iPhone
بسعر لا يصدق في
الخريف الماضي ، أضفنا المزيد من
المستخدمين الجدد إلى تشكيلة iphone 13 مقارنة
بكل من  عمليات الإطلاق الخمس السابقة
في قلب هاتف iphone sc هي
شريحة a15 bionic نفسها مثل iPhone 13. إن
جلب هذا المستوى من الأداء إلى
هواتفنا ذات الأسعار المعقولة هو شيء
يمكن لشركة Apple فقط القيام به
a15 bionic مما يجعل كل تجربة تقريبًا
أفضل
من الأشياء البسيطة مثل تشغيل التطبيقات
والتمرير عبر الصور إلى
أعباء العمل المكثفة مثل معالجة معلومات العمق أثناء التنقل ،
تحزم a15 bionic وحدة معالجة مركزية قوية ذات ستة نواة
للتعامل مع المهام الصعبة بسلاسة وكفاءة ،
فهي أسرع بما يصل إلى 1.8 مرة من iPhone
8 وأسرع مقارنةً بالموديلات القديمة التي
يمتلكها iphone se المنزل  زر
مع معرف اللمس لطريقة آمنة خاصة
وسهلة لإلغاء قفل جهاز iPhone الخاص بك ، قم بتعبئة
رموز المرور وإجراء عمليات شراء باستخدام Apple
pa  يتمتع y
iphone se بعمر بطارية أفضل
مع كفاءة تكامل a15 bionic
مع ios لدينا أحدث
كيمياء للبطارية وتحديثات التصميم الداخلي
، ونحن نقدم 5g إلى
iPhone الأقل تكلفة
حتى يتمكن iphone se من الاستفادة من
أحدث جيل من التكنولوجيا
التي تحصل عليها  سرعة فائقة في التنزيل والتحميل
زمن وصول أقل وتجارب أفضل في
أماكن أكثر ، يأتي هاتف iphone se مع جميع
المزايا المذهلة لنظام ios 15
بما في ذلك الميزات الجديدة مثل التركيز
للمساعدة في تقليل الإلهاء في
الوقت الحالي
وتجربة خرائط جديدة تمامًا
وستحصل على ذكاء  القدرات
التي تحمي خصوصيتك مثل
سيري على الجهاز والإملاء على الجهاز الذي
لم يكن ممكنًا مع الهواتف القديمة ،
سيحصل iPhone se على آخر
تحديثات iOS لسنوات
قادمة ويبدأ في 4 29 فقط.
تبدأ الطلبات المسبقة يوم الجمعة  و iphone
sc سيكونان متاحين في 18 مارس.